hi daniella hi address oh i love that
you added the duh
off the camera just to make sure nobody
was confused and missed the sign
you never know um so i had so much fun
watching this movie you guys it's dark
it's twisted it just what was that
moment for you when you decided to be a
part of this wild
adventure uh it was a it was a
face-to-face moment with
james gunn in a hotel room in beverly
hills
uh at around 12 a.m
you know in the morning it was like late
at night sometime and james came to see
me
uh we sat down i'd read the script
before he come we sat down we had um a
bev
raj i'll say he drank me i didn't
and we talked about it and it was
immediate you know um
here's a director that i admire as a as
a film director but then here
here he was in person and i had spoken
and spoken to him a few times before i
met him and immediately just loved his
vibe you know i knew that i could make
something with him
and he was so enthusiastic about me
joining so i was really
in i love it well danielle i know that
you had to
audition with an actual rat was that fun
it was a really fun experience that i
will never forget in my life
um i i wasn't i i didn't have any
expectations
uh before like having the rats in my
hands
uh but it went well because i guess i'm
here
yeah obviously went very well uh now we
know that bloodsport can't handle
rats throughout the whole film it just
really like that with the rats on set
uh there were rats on set really
you just stayed clear blank
no i'm lying um uh danielle had um
the one of three rats um i think quickie
was one of the names and
um one was chris pratt or chris rat
and then there was another one listen i
i got to know them a little bit only
because
you know i was in love with daniella you
know i love being around her we had a
lot of good bond and she always had this
little rat so i had to be
you know had to figure it out so you
weren't squeamish around okay that's
good that's good to hear
not too much
no it sounds like you are okay most
important
question of the interview if given the
chance who do you think
king shark would eat first out of
everyone on the team
it just peacemaker
i've heard that a lot he's a good male
you know his
muscles and stuff you know king chad
would be really
uh satisfied yeah at least for a few
days daniella what do you think
i would say uh peacemaker too
but uh i would say also ratcatcher too
because
he actually tried to yeah
yeah the
that was such a good moment i love that
scene in the film it's just that there
was a suicide squad
buddy cop film who would you love to see
bloodsport team up with
rap catcher for sure really yeah
yeah yeah i mean you know it's like
sherlock holmes you know sherlock holmes
and
watson it would be blood sport and rat
catcher
danielle would you want to see
ratcatcher 2 team up with bloodsport or
you got somebody else in mind
no no no um
some other interviews people are asking
me like
who i wanted to bond with if i only had
to choose one people
one person and i would say bloodsport
for sure because
he got he has my back and yeah i could
be the silly one and the lazy one and
like the save me one yeah
i love that so much and just wrapping
things up it just was really fun to hear
that bloodsport was able to take down
superman
do you think there's another superhero
that he'd love to get his hands on
uh dude that's a really great question
um i'm not sure
if i want to divulge that i don't want
to set off the rumor trial
but
that's awesome well i hope we get to see
another showdown let's just put that in
the universe
thanks so much guys it was really fun
getting to interview you congrats on the
film
thank you
you